all right what's going on guys it is
twelve o'clock in the morning right now
and I finally decided to shave I need to
go and get my haircut later on today
it's like like it's later today yeah
it's 12 the morning um alright updates
for you guys Civil War okay I have seen
your comments you got something to say
Rob what are you gonna upload part 6 Rob
this part 6 going to be there what
happened to Wolverine so on and so forth
I'm working on it I'm working on it
right now actually I am I am as you guys
know with these videos I do the best I
can to get you guys what you want to see
and and it's it has been so busy today
I've I finished Deadpool kills the
marvel universe part 2 i'm finishing up
the part 5 Civil War tions which has
like Wolverine and like what the whole
thing is when it comes to him and then
i'll be working on part 6 and uploading
part 6 so yeah it's uh oh my god it is
it is crazy busy I've been sitting here
in front of my computer for the last 12
hours working on videos um the next
thing is the Kree of course with acres
of shield Marvel has basically come out
and said yes the blue alien was the Kree
we all knew that like we all knew it was
the Kree we all be were just a matter of
time before mother came on the set is so
I'm working also working on a video
which i have completed explaining the
Kree so yeah that'll be fun too so
there's all kinds of stuff coming in the
next few days or so so yeah it's it's
been a busy day so I just want to keep
you guys in the loop let you guys know
what's going on and yeah I'll catch you
guys later peace